Why Do Men's Bikes Have a Horizontal Crossbar
and Women's Usually Don't?
It would seem that having a slanted crossbar
like on women’s bikes would make much more
sense for men’s bikes, decreasing the chance
of racking the guy if he slips off the pedals
or the like.
However, there is actually a really good reason
to have a horizontal crossbar on a bike; namely,
the horizontal crossbar ends up adding quite
a bit of strength to the frame of the bike.
This was particularly important in some of
the early bikes, which were often made of
significantly weaker materials than modern
day frames, occasionally even being made of
wood.
The problem with this horizontal crossbar
was that women all used to wear dresses.
So when a woman wanted to get on a bike, she’d
have to lift her leg over the bike frame’s
crossbar, which was quite scandalous for the
time as it often exposed quite a bit of leg
and possibly some underwear under her dress.
Thus, bike makers began making bike models
just for women that slanted the top crossbar
down so that the women could mount and dismount
the bikes without lifting their legs very
high.
Modifying the crossbar like that significantly
weakened the frames of the bicycles, but this
was considered acceptable as it wasn’t very
lady like for women to ride their bikes as
roughly as some men anyways.
This tradition has continued to this day,
even though most women don’t go around riding
bikes in dresses or skirts anymore.
For the most part, on modern bikes, this weakening
of the frame by slanting the crossbar isn’t
significant enough to cause any concern for
bikes, even on rough terrain, given modern
materials that the frames are made of.
Indeed, many BMX bikes for men are now designed
with the slanted crossbar to reduce the chance
of injury while doing tricks.
However, among higher end bikes made for women,
this tradition of not having a horizontal
crossbar is starting to go away, even though
the added strength from a horizontal crossbar
isn’t typically necessary anymore, particularly
with carbon fiber frames.
On these high end bikes, the differences between
the men’s and the women’s bikes now tends
to be reflected in the design by accounting
for shorter torsos and arms on most women;
modified hip placement; modified seat design;
and the like.